[Music]
okay so now we're black against a higher
rated opponent
and let's see i want to play a stafford
i'm i don't care
i want to play a stafford gambit because
literally out of the four attempts that
i've made
like three people have declined so
i don't care about educational value
we're playing the stafford knight f6
thank you sarah toomb for the prime
now i have never seen this few people
take on eve okay he's already thinking
that's a bad man there we go
i mean this is actually unbelievable
now in the last game yesterday we played
bishop c5
uh inviting him to take on e5 and
transposing it to the stafford so we're
going to do that again
and we're going to do that again
yeah that's actually pretty incredible
to me awaken for life thank you and
sarah toom d4 so at least he plays
something relatively fresh we get a
fresh position that's nice
d4 is kind of a souped-up scotch
um
but i like the positioning of the bishop
here
obviously it's putting pressure on the
knight
uh so in relation to a scotch
we basically have a scotch
with knight c6 having not been played
it's kind of weird but i like the way
we've developed we're putting immediate
pressure on this pawn so
uh in what order should we develop our
pieces what should we do
um what should we develop first should
we play knight c6 should we play d6
uh all of these moves are okay
but i think the most ambitious approach
would be
to castle i think the most ambitious
approach would be to castle because
there's two things to keep in mind here
the first
there might be a circumstance under
which we want to play d5 in one fell
swoop but it's too early to do that
right now because we're not castled yet
the second idea is that this e4 pawn is
quite weak if he screws around for one
more move we might play rookie eight and
pile up on this pawn so
from the point of view of ambition and
flexibility castles is
i would say uh
more ambitious than d6 and just better
uh
h6 well bishop g5 is not going to be a
big issue we'll deal with it
well more ambitious than d6 i'm not
saying the move itself is that ambitious
knight b3 will drop the bishop back
doesn't really change anything
so the next move is either going to be
rookie 8 or d5 or
you know d6 or knight c6
really depends on what he does how he
positions his pieces
um
e5 as you guys know in such positions is
never dangerous we just respond with
rookie eight
so
you know before he's developed his
bishop this would be way premature
and already he's
he's definitely not in trouble but this
is very challenging for white black's
play is much easier
so we're waiting for him to make a
decision
is right
yeah he's thinking i mean it's not so
easy to figure out
this proper schema i would play bishop
c4 here
if i were white and i could explain the
rationale behind it after the game
there's some tactical reasoning here
that has to be applied
no not sweet
hey amanda
he's already maulding five moves in
well d5 he takes
i'm not sure
um bishop c4d5 i don't think that works
that is black tea yeah yeah
vanilla bean macaroon
i like this particular kind of tea
bishop too so he goes for uh mom lover
with the obligatory gifted sub to ninix
thank you bishop e2 is a little bit
passive
a little bit passive nothing wrong with
that move
and uh
at this point we have enough evidence to
make the decision about how we want to
develop
so what should we do
once again should we go d6 knight c6
what seems uh like the most incisive
yeah definitely rookie definitely uh
press your luck here attack the pawn
and if he goes f3 that's a tremendous
concession because that weakens the
diagonal we can go either d5 okay bishop
g5
uh now how should we continue this is a
very typical sequence of events he tries
to indirectly defend the pawn by pinning
the knight so what we do is we chase the
bishop away if he takes the knight well
that's a very good trade for us if he
goes bishop h4
the key question that a lot of players
and that you should be asking is should
we go g5 does it warrant going g5
because we win the pawn that's clear
on the other hand we weaken our king
side so
we have to weigh the pros and cons some
of you saying no somebody's saying yes i
love it
now let's figure out whether it's okay
the answer is in my opinion is yes g5 is
warranted
first thing to realize is that this is a
pretty important pawn this is a central
pawn
uh that's a big deal to lucifer
let's calculate concretely g5 he has no
sacrifice he's got to drop it back
we take on e4 he'll probably take back
and we take with a rook
and if you look at that resulting
position sorry if you look at that
resulting position his knight on d4 is
hanging
his king is still uncastled so he's tied
up he's gonna have to make a couple of
develop developing moves and in that
time we're gonna be able to consolidate
our king's side so
not very complicated logic here but that
would be my
uh that would be my reasoning for why i
think g5 is worth the risk
uh
those of you who are good at calculating
after 94 94 rookie four
does anybody see
a nasty looking move that white could
try to play in that resulting position
not bishop d3 the bishop is going to be
pinned
daniel nerdski destroys 1800 logic and
facts
knight f5 good job spilling this knight
f5 becomes possible because this bishop
is still
not controlling that square we haven't
moved the d-pawn yet
now a lot of you are looking at this and
saying
is it really worth taking this pawn when
we have a permanently weak in our king
and b are extremely undeveloped
i think it's close we will analyze after
the game he goes nine to five
immediately
um which is interesting
but not as scary as taking first i think
and i'll talk
a lot about this after the game so don't
worry i'll explain
my reasoning more more deeply
now
how should we proceed
so taking his bishop would be a bad idea
because he can play h takes g3 and the
rook opens up and we certainly don't
want him to increase his pressure on
this pawn so i don't like
knight takes bishop
we could play knight takes knight
um let's consider that move for a second
now after knight takes knight what are
white's options let's calculate step by
step does white have to take back the
knight does white have any other moves
yeah so we need to consider the
intermediate move knight takes h6 check
but if you calculate one step further
you just go king h7
he has to recapture the knight and then
that king on h7 captures the knight on
h6 and we're up a piece
so after knight takes e3 he has to play
b takes e3 and in that resulting
position we have a stabilizing move and
i think that stabilizing move gives
black a big advantage who can who can
spot it
knight takes c3 bc queen d3 check we
just take that knight anyway queen f6 is
corrected jeff
take the knight then we play queen f6
some of you may be wondering why i
didn't play queen f6 immediately also
we'll talk about that after the game
um so there's a lot of variations here
i was just writing that down let's go
queen f6 attacking
defending attacking
yes
and
if he somehow plays queen d3 for example
then we're gonna push the d-pawn out
attacking the knight forcing it backward
and we have officially consolidated in
that
position i'm just writing down some
notes that i want to talk about knight
to d4 good move
okay so uh because he's gone knight t4
we can still go d6
but once again we want to develop as
incisively as possible that means
develop while creating threats and
harassing him further so instead of
automatically going d6
what move causes greater difficulty here
for white knight c6 for sure
because immediately piling up the
pressure on the knight on d4 if he takes
our knight c3 is going to hang
very simple logic here
parrots thank you for the gift i
appreciate it
he castles that of course gives up a
second pawn
and there's no reason not to take it in
what order should we take and with what
pieces should we take on d4
well i don't see the reason to give up
the bishop i i like the i like for us to
have a dark squared bishop here just in
case
uh bishops are a little bit better at
protecting weak squares the knights so
knight takes d4 is a better idea
cd4
now queen takes d4 might be tempting
from the perspective of trading queens
but the problem is that that doesn't
actually create a threat
and we allow him to take on c7 there's
no need to give up upon so we would
rather take the bishop thank you draith
for the prime
i hope i'm relatively clear so far
now
once he moves his rook
now is finally the time to play d6
that's a pretty
straightforward move
our king is still a little bit weak we
need to be careful
um and we certainly want to figure out a
way to complete our development he's got
some residual compensation
but if we can make a couple more
consolidating moves i think black will
be in excellent shape
remember guys i answer individual
questions after the game so if you've
got a question hold on to it and i
promise that i'll get to it bishop to f3
attacking the pawn
i think a lot of players here would
automatically respond with rook b8
but let's try to find a slightly more
precise move rook b8 would be just a
little bit passive right it ties the
rook down to the pawn
a better idea is to build up a little
bit of a pawn chain here with c6 making
sure that the bishop to use my favorite
phrase biting
bites on granite
and we could follow up with d5 expanding
the pawn chain even further
now b6 would not be a good idea because
that would drop the pawn with a fork
and even if it were i wouldn't
necessarily want to position my bishop
there
yeah but we couldn't play it immediately
oh yeah yeah like if he didn't do
anything then maybe
more granite
so our idea is to play d5 closing down
the bishop
but keeping an eye on other
possibilities as well
i think we have
such a possibility here we don't need to
play d5 we have an opportunity here to
develop a
which is bishop f5 yeah we have an
opportunity to develop a tempo
completing our development
we will need to
figure out a way to defend this pawn
again
but that's not too hard to do we've our
pieces are now fully mobilized
once again rook b8 is sub-optimal i
don't love
tying down an entire piece a heavy piece
to the defense of the pawn
so what some people forget is that you
can sometimes intercept
your opponent's attackers particularly
the queen and rook can be intercepted
and so the move bishop b6 comes to mind
another great move is rookie seven
because
yes the rook is a little bit tied down
but on the other hand you're also
preparing to double rooks and that's
even better than bishop b6 i love the
move rookie seven because it protects
the pawn and
prepares to double the rogues if we need
extra protection we can drop the bishop
to b6 as well but i don't see a reason
that we need to move this bishop it's
defended by the queen
okay so definitely we want to double and
trade on our own terms
and you can see this guy is good i mean
these people
you know 1900 these are going to be very
combative games
all right takes takes we have the e-file
all to ourselves
and now we're strategizing what's going
to be the next move what do we want to
do
well in general a queen trade would
benefit us because we're up two puns
right so that's one approach we could
take is play queen e6
um
so let's flesh that out for a second has
he prevented us from playing queen e6
let's ask the sam shanklin question what
happens if i do it anyway
he's not threatening the bishop at all
because of the backrank made as magnus
carlsen can tell you
but wait a second before you play that
move
you want to keep your eyes peeled for
more concrete options
um and this is something that some
players forget to do queen e6 is a
perfectly good move but you have one
other move which wins the game on the
spot
what's the drawback of rook d1 well
noticing this pawn on g5
this bishop on f3 all of a sudden is
kind of trapped it's biting on granite
now it doesn't have a retreat and so
what move comes
uh g4
yeah trapping the bishop how did i see
that i can't i would be lying to you if
i said that i like somehow logically
arrived at the fact that i had had this
move i just saw it my pattern
recognition indicated it i'll show you a
game
afterwards uh that's sort of a very
famous instance of something like this
happening okay c3 so he's
counter-attacking our bishop where
should we where should we put it
what would be the most solid square for
our bishop yeah simply push it back to
c5
making sure this pawn is protected
and that's it the game is over he's
losing another piece and with it the
game
uh i could take i could have taken the
pawn for sure but i didn't want to
burden myself with
you know various shenanigans
we've uh we have enough extra material
here to last us a lifetime
so i hope this all made sense
yeah he's
he's just busted the bishop is trapped
in the meantime i'm going to find the
game that i want to show you guys
afterward that
is one of the
you know studying such a game can help
you
find g4 instinctively and he resigns
so
first since we're on this topic let me
let me show you guys
your malinsky um
of course was born in russia and
he's lived in the us for many many
decades now he originally moved to san
francisco so that's where i met him
a very very strong player he actually
became a grandmaster at age 36 i think
which is pretty cool
shows you that you could do it when
you're old
or older
um
old i'm already old so
you can even do it in your 70s
yeah i think your malinsky became a gm
at 36.
now um
okay you know what i mean chess in chess
terms
so this is kasparov your malinsky gary
was 12 years old at the time this game
was played
uh under 18 soviet championship final
round crucial game tournament deciding
game
your malinsky plays an alakan this is a
classic alakan structure and in this
position your malinsky plays a very
classic move
uh he plays knight eight to e7
uh aiming potentially to come to f5 with
his knight and attack the pawn on d4
and according to the story of kasparov's
coach at the time alexander nikitin
who's in i am he's still alive
uh nikita was in the playing hall he was
watching the game
and when
97 was played
um
he
you know he almost had a sort of he
heart palpitations began he started
praying rage
but gary after
a little while played knight b3 just
improving
uh the protection of the d4 pawn
and the king was absolutely furious
and for many years after this game gary
kasparov earned himself the nickname g4
because what gary had missed was the
move g4
bishop g6 and g5 trapping the bishop on
f6 this is believe it or not a pretty
common trap in the alakin
gary missed this
um so i saw this game many many years
ago
i might have shown this game before i
don't remember
but um anyways just since we're on the
topic let's quickly analyze and see if
we can get some blitzen
yeah that
dumb good spy how did he become world
champion
all right
um
so back to
this
okay
so again
no stafford i guess he played d4 which
is a little bit inaccurate i like
black's position here
and at this point i was suggesting the
move bishop c4 for him
and the point is that after rookie 8
castles
knight takes e4
if my
memory serves if my calculation serves
me correctly
uh there is a very nice tactic here for
white if you play the italian and stuff
you should be familiar with this type of
idea
what am i talking about
yeah bishop takes f7 is correct king
takes f7 now i would take the knight
here
uh just to clear the air a little bit
now after rook takes d4 you have to be
very careful
the muppo most popular wrong answer is
queen f3 because you think that you win
the rook
but if you calculate one step further
don't stop calculating what move does
black have here to get a lot of stuff
for the rook
queen f6 we can have six queen takes e4
bishop d4 and okay black is extremely
underdeveloped so maybe white is okay
here but it's two pieces for a rook
there's no need to allow that
the bishop on c5 is also undefended so
queen h5
is a safer possibility and moreover
after king g8 now you can switch back to
the idea of winning the rook because
there's no way to get the knight for it
queen d5 check and if rookie 6 the
knight takes c6 some very nice lines
here just shows you how difficult it is
to play when you're not developed and
half of the side is not developed
so
uh so that would have been out of the
question i would have played d6 and we
would have gotten a normal position
but
um
i think that was preferable to what to
what he did
so bishop e2 is just a little too
passive rookie e8
and okay bishop g5 i think is fine as
long as he plays very accurately i
really don't see an alternative
if white had played f3 we could have
struck him in the center with d5 an
amazing position here
um
so
at this point he kind of has to try this
h6
bishop h4 g5 so how did i know
that i could get away with this i've
talked about this before i think a
couple of days ago
you can see in the speed run a clear
shift i think when we hit around 1700
where
the games before
were all about applying the rules
playing it by the book
you know we were winning a lot of games
out of the opening
now we've entered a situation where
to progress further you need to know
the rules you need to be fluent with
chess principles but you also need to
know when to violate them you need to
know
when to make that particular judgment
call oh i'm underdeveloped
i'm weakening my king but i can get away
with it because of the specific
properties of the position and that's a
great example of that
where calculation and sort of concrete
thinking is going to transcend
general reasoning
um and there's a bunch of quotes about
this from various world champions so the
particular
fact
that i think there's two things as i
explained during the game that
convince my intuition that i can get
away with this and then there's the
calculation component the first is that
after 94 rookie 4 the night is hanging
that buys me a tempo potentially the
second thing is that his king is
uncastled that's another tempo because
he's going to have to waste time to
castle and this is all about whether
black can consolidate if i can bring all
these pieces out
nobody will deny that this would have
been a good good option right
so
knight f5 here would have been a far
more robust option and after queen f6
in contrast to what happened in the game
you can see that his pawn in the game
was on c3 which really hurts him
here he doesn't have to worry about the
threat of queen c3 check
this unties his hands and allows him to
play what move who can spot a very
strong move for white here
so think about how you can defend 25
from gem jim oh my gosh
crazy stuff again
queen d5 no not queen d6 queen d5 is
correct i mean d5 is correct
queen d5 is correct thank you gemini i
appreciate it
thank you for the 25.
oh my lance
yeah queen d5 is absolutely correct
and uh the rook is attacked the bishop
is attacked
i saw this move it's important not to
panic you calculate this you say oh my
gosh i mean everything is hanging
the reality is not everything is not
hanging only two things are hanging the
rook and the bishop
and there's a couple of ways that you
can save both of them um the first is
bishop before check
because if he plays c3
you can try bishop take c3 check
although after king f1 things get a
little bit complicated but that wasn't
what i intended
there are several ways of
defending two pieces at the same time
and you can literally defend them or you
can create a counter threat this is what
people often struggle with
now in which direction can this counter
threat be created well i'm looking at
this bishop i'm x-raying it with the
rook
that should
allow you to start searching for ways to
maybe perhaps reinforce the threat on
that bishop and the move queen e6 comes
to and this is the move that i was
intending to play had he gone for this
line
now if queen takes b2
i see how this is tempting but he just
castles
and after rookie two queen c5 you know
at this point with such a monster knight
i would be really worried to have this
with with black
um
d6 would give up the rook
so queen e6 i think is an accurate move
because after queen takes
you could even take with the pawn and he
reestablishes material equality so what
i calculated here
was you could also play rookie six
and after bishop takes c7 he could try
to lock this bishop out with d6 i think
black's position is nice because white
can't castle the bishop is in some
trouble i think concretely
black is a great position after bishop
a5 you can play rookie 2 and bishop f5
getting two rooks for the piece
so
you know these are very complicated
tactical lines but there's nothing crazy
about them i mean they're just
variations
and every move within the variation
should make sense
yeah but knight h6 first so who invited
you
yeah that is true knight h6 but gear
king h7 i thought
and after
okay so this is illegal and after queen
takes c6
um
what was i thinking
after queen takes c6 i guess you have to
play fp which is undesirable is it
because of knight g4
and here i'm very underdeveloped in the
end game
yeah i don't know who invited robert to
spoil the party
i suppose
hmm
where should we go
the problem is you can't go king f8
because if queen takes d5
and if king g7 then queen takes g5 man
that is an annoying queen
yeah so you have to go for this line
and then
yeah and then
rookie six knight f7 the knight
evacuates wow that's pretty cool so i
guess this is good for white i guess
queen e6 is not the best move
um
so maybe this was not worth the risk
after all i was also contemplating rook
take c2 check sacking the exchange and
getting the king out into the open and
then going d6 this would be more in
hess's style
knight has to drop back you go knight c6
this i like a lot more
and everything is falling here b2 is
hanging i think black's got nice
compensation
just shows you the extent of
complexity that you see in these kinds
of positions
yeah this is uh this is both of our
styles i guess
and then the rook comes out the king is
permanently weak here which makes this
hard to play
you can't drop the queen back because of
the fork
so this is just crappy uh and that's
probably what i should have done rook
take c2 check
um
and so
that calculation informs
your opinion of whether you can take on
e4 right that's just calculation there's
there's a little bit less verbal logic
than there used to be
and that's what makes improving a little
bit daunting
is just that you you still have verbal
logic you still apply principles but
there's a little bit less of that at
this level a little bit more concrete
calculation thank you curious
gifting to some unnamed gm
so anyways um he went knight f5
immediately which is a mistake i take c3
and now if he takes on h6 we play king
h7 and he cannot save the knight because
he also has to take this knight
king takes h6
um
yeah but then still queen d5 i think
this is even scarier because now the
queen is immobilized so i guess maybe
queen eight here but
i don't know castles this looks very
very scary
uh anyways
takes takes queen f6
he's got to drop the knight back i mean
now he can't this doesn't make any sense
it doesn't attack the rook anymore and
of course queen c3 wins
uh queen d3 i thought he might play but
again just d6 and now we fully
consolidated now once he won knight d4
we go knight c6
castles we win a second pawn
and the rest is a matter of just
consolidating our advantage d6 c6
bishop f5 seizing the opportunity to
develop a tempo
making sure that the pawn is protected
doubling rooks
and then seeing the opportunity to trap
his bishop originally i was going to
play queen e6 and force the queen trade
or at least try to force the queen trade
because of the backrank mate but you
should always spend a couple of seconds
looking for
looking for a better move right are
there any other candidate moves and
sometimes you save yourself a lot of
work when you do that g4
and uh white loses the bishop so he
resigned so a simple game
except for that one moment i mean i
think the end of the game was pretty
simple but the opening was
the opening was very interesting so
i'm happy we played it any questions
before i move on to some blitz
all right nice looks like we're clear
what was the opening called well this is
an attempted stafford gambit
which was declined for like the 18th
time
so
not the best for educational
value
but
i wanted to have some fun
[Music]